so one of the most compelling stories
from your book uh that i found
engrossing was the story of a guy named
damian patton
and so damien patton's a
young jewish boy kind of lost soul
and then he winds up being radicalized
and joins a white supremacist group yeah
uh even participates becomes something
of a young star and viewer yeah uh
and
it's obviously
um
something that people don't even imagine
possible uh that where they didn't know
he was jewish yeah that's right and he
was concerned that he'd be outed as
jewish like he brought one of his
new friends home and then his mom's like
what the hell you're a skinhead you're
jewish
and then he had to deny it
um
so
i thought this story was so powerful and
humanizing because what it showed was
that this radicalization
uh can
prey upon or or it it it feels like a
human need that people have yeah almost
regardless of background that's right i
mean i think
people yearn for community
right
especially that lost soul you know is so
eager to find a welcoming group where he
or she can fit in and in damien's case
he was from a broken home
didn't have strong role models found
himself kind of
attracted to gangs
first like latino gang because he had a
friend who was hispanic and then
eventually got pulled into the white
supremacist movement
and it's extraordinary to think that
someone again could deny who they were
and get pulled into something so toxic
and clearly like self-destructive but he
did
and not only did he get involved with
them he traveled from southern
california to tennessee
they committed a crime he was in the car
with two adults when he was still a
minor and they shot up a synagogue you
know thankfully no one was killed but
not for lack of effort
and uh they were arrested
and they were
arrested
indicted and sentenced but he was a
minor so as the two guys went to prison
he was let off and then he went on to
join the military moved found community
there eventually found he was pretty
good at coding
built a successful tech company venture
backed on his way to an ipo in the
burgeoning tech scene in salt lake city
where there's some really some
interesting stuff happening and uh got
but got outed some investigative
reporter found out his past which damien
had never come clean about and he was
outed
and he was humiliated
and he was literally
fired from the company that he built
with his bare hands from the ground up
and relieved none of his
responsibilities the ceo pushed out
entirely by the board yeah so i think
this is really important because this is
about when you met him when he came to
your attention yeah so someone in their
distant past their adolescence
is affiliated or is a white supremacist
uh
serves in the military goes on to become
a business leader uh years and years
pass and then someone produces uh
records being like hey this person
uh was a white supremacist yes it has
tattoos to that effect yeah um and so if
you just look at that headline you just
think well well this person's terrible
because you know like that they were an
active white supremacist uh meanwhile
uh this person had had like a completely
different life arc yeah you know and and
i mean he had a family yeah yeah which
happened obviously after he was long
after yeah long after and so then the
company looks at him and says well you
got to go because like we can't have
like a white supremacist founder uh you
know that that's going to like destroy
the company like where you know we're
trying to go public yeah um
and then he's looking at it like look
this is a part of my life that has
like not been a part of my life for
decades and decades yeah and so when you
were brought in to talk to him you know
like and it was one of the things i
admired about uh both
you know your account in the book um and
your work is that you
treated him like a human being of course
yeah i mean
i don't know that i deserve credit for
that i think that's the basic
what happened was
a friend of mine because i worked in
silicon valley for many years
who was a venture capitalist
jewish fellow
uh called me and said hey jonathan i
know this i'm an investor in this guy's
company
it's a crazy story would you talk to him
so first of all he had a valid
introduction from someone that i trusted
but i also called him because
like you know nick cannon who's a friend
has this phrase that he uses which i've
wholesale adopted
uh
and take credit for
uh he says he doesn't believe in cancel
culture he believes in council culture
and i think there's so much truth to
that so in damien's case
yeah he erred yeah he sinned but if you
like look i'm jewish i believe that
we're all created in god's image but
we're not god we're imperfect and we air
and we make mistakes
and the thing is can you learn from
those mistakes can you rep are you
willing to acknowledge the error
apologize maybe to those you've heard
and repent and so i called this fellow
and said it and look the first
conversation we had
we was a it was a phone call he was at
an airport in long beach
and he was basically speechless
i say i'm just calling to reach out let
you know i'm here i'm happy to talk to
you and then we got on a zoom like a
couple days later andrew and he was
glassy-eyed
and trying to make sense of what was
happening he just seen his reputation
uh destroyed and is his life completely
upended the whole his every exactly it
was like he was literally in a building
and the entire building was burning down
around him and he had no way out
and then
we talked again a week later and then a
week later and a week later and then the
weeks became months and the months
became years and i've talked to damien
not quite every week
but you know dozens and dozens and
dozens and dozens of weeks
and i did that because i've watched him
evolve and grow not just you know what's
the word like not just externally
you know again from a white supremacist
who joins the navy who becomes a coder
and an entrepreneur and a ceo but like
internally as a person who's reckoned
with his past
and resolved himself to do better and i
i don't i think as head of the adl like
yeah i deal with big geopolitical issues
and whatnot but i also like i'm a human
being
and so helping him find his path has
been one of the most rewarding
experiences i've had in this job
i i think
council culture should be the new norman
standard 100 uh and it's one
uh one thing that i i admire about what
you advocate in your book
um which is that
look there has to be a path to
understanding or redemption
uh for people that want it i mean if
someone that's right
now that's really important like if you
are a serial offender if you are
unwilling to acknowledge
what you've done what you're doing
if you
will only listen to yourself in the
counsel of the people that you trust
rather than those who you've hurt
like that's a different story like i
don't have patience for people
who uh
you know continue to offend but if
you're willing to try
i think it's up to the rest of us to be
willing to help you
you know i don't know i should say that
for everyone but i think it's my job and
i think it's those of us in public life
andrew
can always do better
so
we talked about how there was this wave
of democratization and then it seems to
be reversing
uh and uh a woman
i spoke to recently barbara walter wrote
a book oh yeah that suggests a civil war
yeah that suggests that social media
might be part of
the reversal yeah uh that there is
something of a negative correlation
between
uh
social media adoption and
democratization which was a very
uh you know striking negative
correlation um you started
uh
an anti-facebook campaign yeah um that
was the biggest most significant effort
i've seen yeah you got uh dozens of
major corporations uh to get on board
what catalyzed that effort
so
first of all i would just recognize like
professor walter like she's a professor
at ucsd
i really admire her scholarship and her
book is terrific
and i think there's something to what
she said about the pernicious role of
social media so when i joined adl you
know again i had worked in the valley
i'd worked inside google like i
understand these companies but i
was seeing how facebook was the front
line in fighting hate so adl opened a
center in silicon valley in 2017. i
think we're the first civil rights group
have a physical presence we were in palo
alto off university road yeah
and i and i didn't you know i didn't put
like some non-profit fundraiser to run
it i recruited a guy from reddit the guy
who used to be bp for revenue products
at reddit to run it so it's staffed with
software engineers and data scientists
and programmers and we engage on a
day-to-day basis with all the big
companies from from you know from amazon
to zoom from like from apple to youtube
google and instagram and of course
facebook we'll talk about that in
twitter and tick tock
we're working with the gaming companies
and the problems there are off off the
[ __ ] wall
go ahead man you can swear on this
podcast but they're off the wall uh
and the messaging platforms so we work
with all these different kind of arenas
but to the point that you were making
into what professor walter said
like there's no question that while many
of them and we work with them to
identify hate speech and help them
understand what extremists are doing the
toughest one to work with by far is
facebook
wow i mean
so we do and you've met with uh mark
zuckerberg many times yeah and look like
there's a lot of good people there who
mean well i would say that i have
friends who work at baseball sure but
the kind of group thing that happens
there is extraordinary and whereas a lot
of the companies again none of them are
clean they're all have their issues
but
we do an annual survey of online hate
and harassment doing it for years
the pla and the data is crazy
42 of people use social media say that
they've been on bullied online 28
this is our 2021 survey we haven't done
this years yet
uh 28 it's probably worse 28 say they've
been systematically like continually
bullied on or stalked or you know
harassed online but the place where it
happens the most facebook it happens on
facebook three times as often as any
other platform
three times as often the instagram
numbers are terrible too
and while we've brought this stuff to
these companies again and again we had a
situation in the summer of 2020
right after the death of george floyd
where we were you know my analysts
watched the extremists i mean that's
what we do and we had extremes
they all do and lots of counseling but
we saw on facebook groups the extremists
organizing to disrupt the black lives
matter protests and we brought that to
facebook and they wouldn't do anything
about it i mean the highest value there
is really freedom of expression
but i don't think dude it's freedom of
money
[Laughter]
freedom of revenue but like you know
like my friend sasha baron cohen says i
don't think freedom of speech equals
freedom of reach but they've allowed the
lunatic fringe to go from the fringe
right into the mainstream
and so i reached out to derek johnson
who runs the naacp
and to rashad robinson who runs a group
called color of changes of course we
need to get organized and so we launched
this campaign we called it stop paid for
problem that's right that's right yes
okay so you kick off stop paid for
profit which is a very audacious
campaign
uh and you do wind up with some major
corporate we had
i tell you what when we started the
campaign we said take we started it in
june
we said take the month of july off
facebook we told companies don't
advertise on facebook for the month of
july and when we started the campaign we
had we didn't have a single company
lined up and it was very audacious
um it's a little bit like my
presidential campaign
i suppose
um
three weeks later we had over 1100
companies the biggest brands in the
world incredible coca-cola mcdonald's so
why were they so deceptive do you think
what like i'll tell you exactly why
because we gave them examples of like
white supremacist and anti-semitic and
racist content on facebook like flighted
against their ads yeah that's pretty
convincing so here's an amazon ad you
know next to a just like a bloody truck
that says let's go get the next george
floyd
or
here's a salesforce ad or a verizon ad
and so on and so forth
and you put that out there and howard
schultz says i don't want starbucks
advertising alongside the nazis but
that's what facebook was doing
and you know like i've talked to them
many times i had a conversation once
with mark and he said around all of this
i think maybe that's in the book and he
said you know jonathan a few years ago
all of the hate content on facebook was
user reported he said to me today 88
is is caught by our ai before users even
see it so i think we're doing pretty
good
and i was and i said okay well i used to
be an executive at starbucks we didn't
get to say 88 of our coffee doesn't have
poison in it so we think we're doing
pretty good
yeah especially if you imagine
the number of messages they're talking
about i mean you have 12
out there 12 of an enormous number is an
enormous number yes that is the law of
large numbers it's huge
and
as much as we knew then i mean you know
the way we got the concessions all these
companies came off and then we organized
with sasha and leo dicaprio and selena
gomez the campaign to get celebrities
off instagram kim kardashian they all
joined us so for a week in august they
all got off the platform maybe they were
grateful not to have to post where we
yeah they were i did hear that i heard
people like oh my god thank goodness but
it also is important to them like it's
important to their brands so they engage
with their fans
so those two things led facebook's okay
we're actually ready to talk and they
did what we asked they hired a vp for
civil rights like we asked they started
classifying holocaust denialism as hate
speech like we asked they took off white
supremacist groups like we asked they
they released the results of an audit
they agreed to do an audit i mean they
did a bunch of things
it's not nearly enough
and you know i've heard people say well
what do you expect
and stuff is difficult
like the this is the most sophisticated
platform in the history of capitalism
yes they will earn 120 billion dollars
this year like a 24 net margin
i mean yeah you know if the balance was
reversed where look they're making more
money by getting that 88 up to
99.99 as opposed to less money like you
know they'd get it right you are
entirely correct like that's exactly the
right calculus so the problem is you're
saying the incentives are totally
misaligned
there's no regulatory oversight because
there's a thing in the law called
section 230 and they have these written
before facebook along with yeah like
1996 i think
and uh
you know i mean there's this hyper
libertarian ethos inside the company and
many of us might self-identify as
libertarians
but there's a problem when
that libertarianism involves again using
this product
and the product to
literally not just target
and stalk
but to you know cause physical harm to
people which we've seen happen
on facebook and on these other platforms
and you know the reality is all i would
say andrew to your point about the how
do you get it tonight what if it would
you know 99.9 increase the revenues they
took the nazis off
like
you know uh think about jay and jay the
big pharma company so when they had a
tylenol scare in the 80s
right where a few bottles of tylenol
were tampered with in chicago
like
every freaking bottle off the shelves
every bottle off every shelf in america
and didn't put them back until they'd
reformulated or redesigned the packaging
and it turns out that was probably not
even like it wasn't even there they
could have argued like look this is not
something that we need to
you know respond to at this scale
correct um but they did that or i you
know i used to be in the beverage
business we were talking about that
odwala is a you know ready-to-drink
juice brand and they had a situation
where one bottle in the bay area this is
in the 90s had it was it's a non-flash
pasteurized juice
so you can get you know things in it if
you will like bacteria wanna and a
toddler drank a bottle of a dwala
and got e coli and died it could be
lethal for a little kid
and so what did odwalla do they took
every bottle off every shelf in america
and redesigned the production process
so
if odwalla can do it if jnj can do it
literally one of the most innovative
companies in the history of business
should they should do whatever other
business does take the product off the
shelf and fix it like knock the nazis
off the platform like it isn't that hard
actually you know interestingly enough
and in a timely way there was an
announcement yesterday by facebook that
they are now allowing ukrainians to say
that they want to murder russians or
they want to kill putin you know they
said they are now allowing that because
of the war
like i don't want mark zuckerberg
deciding what kind of hate speech is
okay or not okay
like you wouldn't allow
you you wouldn't allow a ukrainian to go
on
the uh i don't know an nbc or the new
york times right he wants to murder all
ukrainians like facebook should just
abide by the same rules the same kind of
standards that every other media
platform abides by it does really boil
down to mark doesn't it i mean what i
hear about that company is that it's
very very centralized top down slash all
the major decisions get yet funneled
through mark now we're get now we get to
like again these broader issues you know
it may seem off topic but mark controls
64 some odd percent of the shares he has
these crazy class a shares give him all
the voting rights he's purged the board
of all the independent directors so
there's no fiduciary responsibility
there it's the mark show
uh that kind of power vested in one
person
i don't know clearly it's not good
governance
vis-a-vis like the corporate world and
again i think invest the company is too
big and it has too much power in any one
person
yeah uh if i had won the presidency i
was going to to
um
i was going to go to work with the
social media companies honestly because
i just didn't see a way that you could
try and bring the country together that
didn't involve
a very very significant overhaul of
their business practices and and
repeal section 230 make them liable like
every other business if you did that and
just that
now look it may create some there may be
some it would create some changes right
like maybe i wouldn't have as many a
restaurant would have as many you know
yelp ratings or something
but the reality is is
we can see the consequences of unbridled
unfettered
totally unregulated
social media and we're living with the
consequences today
[Music]
you